are two reasons why candy isn't working
her left knee and her right knee I'm 63.
I'm gonna have them replaced I I don't
know
the afterwards
she wants to get back to work in nursing
but she's temporarily on Universal
Credit yeah it's hard it's very very
hard I owe a lot of money for electric
for gas
everything if they decided not to keep
Universal Credit up with inflation what
would it do
then how are we gonna how are we gonna
live
threats from conservative politicians to
go even harder on benefit claimants are
divisive here
in the cafe we found Sheila who's
surviving by sharing her husband's
pension because hers has been delayed I
mean at one time
I would have tea but you can't do that
you've got to decide when that's the
right time to do that haranga is
pointing in just one direction to the
government of course because I'm not
sure that they're listening not really
listening this area is very deprived and
you you can see that people are worrying
that you know you can just see it in the
quietness
say hello to the moon at the baby
sensory class just around the corner
Jack's mum will soon be back at work
there's no other option
and every mom here is working out what
to cut back on the pinch is getting
tighter every month and then you think
about Christmas and it's his first
Christmas and and you want that to be
special as well and you've got to really
think about that a lot more than we
typically would have had to before in
terms of budgeting you know you want it
to be everything for him to give him
those memories and yes we're just trying
our hardest really
the more that we see this struggle the
more familiar it becomes but when you
speak to people up and down the country
working with families trying to stop
them falling into crisis they say this
is not normal and it can't be allowed to
become normal
it just reflects where we are this
autumn
for too many families it's not a good
place
Tom palminter Sky News West Yorkshire